[Music]
spread your wings as you go when God
takes you back you say
it's week six yeah this is kind of what
it is I'm just gonna crack this this for
you every single partner that I've had I
go hey just say you know week six is
gonna come and you're gonna want to
you're gonna want to bail it's gonna be
the hardest week that you will have in
the competition because it's that middle
hump I said this to Jordan he's like no
no no no week six oh crap it's just it's
the midpoint of the competition all of
us have been working so hard and it's
where people start expecting more and
want to see more and more and more new
trying to give that but it's it's hard
and so we kind of knew that was coming
but I'm so I could not be more proud of
how well he handled this week and got
through it and came out on top it was a
night of mistakes wardrobe malfunctions
and some perfect tens
[Music]
Shania Twain
none of those things matter I love the
show and I love the experience and I
love Lindsay and I want her to win so
badly it hurts me I lose sleep over it
at times especially when I'm given a
style that I know is gonna kill my hips
I have history of hip hip issues and
injuries and and for me personally I
just want to give her everything that I
possibly can week in and week out so
that she can feel good and know that
we're gonna do really well on a Monday
and I mean that it causes me to lose
sleep
you